we're going to going to go to Russell
City who joins us from Istanbul and how
is the Turkish government going about
handling this
well it is a litmus test for the
government just ahead of the election so
turkey with in in less than three months
is going to have a general election
which is going to determine which party
is going to form the majority in the
Parliament and also who is going to be
the next president of Turkey so in that
sense it is a litmus test for the
current government and also an
opportunity for the opposition in the
country so president erdogan and his
party probably is going to face the most
difficult election in his political
career as already the economy in the
country is not doing well so the prices
are quite High and the inflation the
annual inflation is around 80 percent so
in that sense leaving a popularity
however for now the polls show that it's
50 50 but in any way most of the experts
agree that it is going to be the most
difficult election that president one is
going to face through his political
carrier so the proposition in the
country is already criticizing the
government and saying that many of these
buildings that have collapsed through
this this earthquake were old and they
didn't pass the past they are not
durable they are not sustainable and
they definitely do not have this
certificate approved by the authorities
regarding the task about the the
earthquake so the government is already
being criticized and one of the other
indicator here is is that so many of the
cities that have been hit hardest in
these earthquake or the Turkish majority
cities like the arbuckers like urfa and
adyama so the Kurdish Wars in this
election are going to be quite
significant in determining who is going
to win so in that sense it is another
critical task for the for the government
the government says that they have
mobilized all the means that turkey has
so the the all the rescue team are
already there the local rescue teams are
there and from the the largest cities of
turkey like Ankara and Istanbul and
under the other Regional centers there
have been uh rescue teams mobilized
their vehicles as well ambient Vehicles
including uh the vehicles that have been
deployed and also the municipalities
local municipalities and the Civil
societies so turkey Investments they're
going to say that we are we are
mobilizing all the governmental and
civil means to handle the distribution
now we can we can say that it is a kind
of race now a competition between the
government and also the opposition they
both are focusing on it and mobilizing
all the means because it's not only
going to be critical for the government
but also the performance of the
opposition in Turkey also is going to a
lot so one of the other critical part is
is that how the government is going to
handle the aftermath of this earthquake
so turkey through the time so the turkey
is not a state it's not danger to the
earthquake it has the ability uh that
develop through the time because it has
been hit hard in 99 and then the recent
years and so on so almost every year in
in in low out of magnitudes or high
magnitude turkey is used to the
earthquakes however in Turkey people
will regard the government for all the
success or feel they are being on how it
handles the aftermath of this earthquake
so will people be provided
new houses will they be provided
sheltered will they have the conditions
humanitarian conditions that at least
they can survive while they get their
new houses so that is going to be
another test because in Turkey now it's
winter the the air con the weather
conditions are quite difficult so
majority of turkey now is under snow and
just at the beginning of this week
actually the the the cold days have hit
turkey including Istanbul and the
largest cities but particularly the
south eastern North turkey which has
been affected most by the earthquake is
having a tough weather conditions so in
that sense as I said turkey is not
danger to the earthquakes and through
the time it developed the abilities to
handle the natural disasters but the
government has almost around 80 days and
it's going to face an important
significant election which for many it
could be it will it is the the most
critical election of 2023 in the world
and so definitely a failure will cost
Chris nerdon and his party dearly but on
the other hand it a Christianity for the
opposition in Turkey as well how they
are going to conduct their campaign how
they are going to handle the aftermath
of this earthquake it's quite important
for now but it had that tool definitely
is rising as of now it is and 284 and
there are more than 500 injured people
but as the rescue affords are still on
the way uh the concerns here that the
numbers the figures could go much much
upper and higher hour by hour indeed
thank you so much for your your Insight
there thank you that is our Russell
certa for us in Istanbul
earlier we spoke with Karim kinnick who
is the head of the Turkish red crescent
he says the group is currently using all
resources available
we have 76 casualties and 40
440 injured people we have
and this is the S4 level disaster
announced by the offered Turkish
disaster Authority it means an its
International
disaster International level disaster so
the first the Turkish Disaster Response
plan activated by the African
our all capacities shelter food rescue
and search capacities and health
capacities deployed to the affected
provinces and Turkish red person by
their branches and Regional and
sub-regional branches they're supporting
USB activities at the field in seven
provinces and we deployed other
shelters and food capacity from
different disasters
response centers from different
provinces of the turkey and we are as a
responsible for the Blood Services at
Turkish red crescent
provided
needy blood to the hospitals that we
call our students for blood donations in
every provinces in
our Blood Centers because
unfortunately our estimation that the
casualties will be rise up and we the
the black meat will be arrived as well
so we have coordinations
crisis centers in each provinces and in
headquarters Ankara as well
there was the head of the Turkish red
crescent who we spoke to not long ago
and a member of the Syrian Civil Defense
in the city of Sulkin describes the
situation there as catastrophic
[Music]
civilian buildings have completely been
destroyed due to an earthquake that hit
the northwest of Syria around 4 30 in
the morning the situation is dire and
catastrophic tens of buildings have
fallen in the city of selkin there's a
complete electrical blackout it's really
catastrophic everyone is on the streets
the buildings are either destroyed or
barely holding here
well let's speak to his own a hotter who
joins us now from Beirut and uh Zayna
what are you hearing from your contacts
in Syria uh we know the death toll there
is well into the hundreds now as well
what's the impact been like there
a state of emergency has been declared
in a number of areas have also been
declared a disastrous
the human toll is climbing it's already
in the hundreds uh the earthquake the
epicenter was in Turkey but many areas
in Syria were affected many provinces
some under the control of the government
others under the control of the
opposition Syrian State media says
nearly 240 people were killed in areas
under the government's control I've been
speaking to the white helmets this is
the main Rescue Team a civil defense
team in opposition controlled areas
they're saying that they still don't
have uh you know a casualty toll they're
telling me the numbers in the dozens at
least 80 people especially in
opposition-controlled areas a lot of
buildings collapse because their
structures were weak after 10 years of
Civil War many of those areas were
repeatedly bombarded in airstrikes or
artillery shelling and you can see from
the videos emerging from the area how
really catastrophic and catastrophic
that situation as you can actually see
one building collapse after the other
people are trapped underneath the rubble
and this is an area which lacks the
resources there is no State and some
civilians are helping to dig through the
rubble using using their bare hands now
also you have the problem of hospitals
because in opposition-controlled areas
Health Facilities were repeatedly
targeted over over the course of the war
and there's also a lack of doctors in
government-controlled areas also they're
facing another crisis and that is a
cash-strapped state which is unable to
provide any services to its people so
the human toll is climbing widespread
damage calls for international
assistance to help them deal with this
disaster which really struck in the
middle of the night people were asleep
people were many people were in their
homes and we have to remember something
this is going to create even more idps
people who have no homes already in that
area millions of people live live in
tents you mentioned International
assistance and that's already been
pledged to Takia but what about Syria
obviously things there are much more
complicated aren't they
well yes it is a
the areas are really divided by front
lines and governments held territories
you do have the United Nations operating
they most likely will mobilize as much
as as much as possible but up in the
Northwest and the opposition controlled
Northwest people really rely on local
ngos help from from small organizations
as well as turkey turkey really provides
a lot of assistance to the people in in
the in the North in the opposition
controlled North and as we have been
hearing the situation in Turkey itself
is is a disaster so where are these
people going to receive help from
doctors in hospitals are posting videos
on YouTube saying that they need
medicine and and they need support and
so it is a it's a very dire situation
for people who who really are already on
their knees after a decade of War people
who are struggling to put food on the
table and the weather conditions is
really
um is really posing a challenge as you
can see behind me the rain has stopped
for for a bit but there has been a
severe storm a rain and snow affecting
this this whole region
and you felt the uh the earthquake there
in Lebanon as well has there been any
reports of damage
minor damage
but that Tremor was very powerful just
after 3 A.M
um I can tell you mostly everybody woke
up from that Tremor which according to
the interior Ministry lasted for some 40
seconds and then there were aftershocks
a lot of people evacuated buildings they
stayed in their cars they stayed in
their streets this is a traumatized City
I must say nearly two and a half years
ago one of the biggest non-nuclear
explosions destroyed and leveled
neighborhoods so it brought back
memories
um especially when the earth started to
shake people did not know what was what
was going on and people were really
concerned because this is a
cash-strapped country a bankrupt state
which is unable to deal with any
disaster
no Personnel no equipment even after
that explosion back in August 2020
without International assistance they
would have not been able to remove a lot
of people from underneath underneath the
rubble so people were are really
concerned about this so far minor damage
but we know that especially up in the
north of the country a lot of the
buildings risk collapse so a lot of
people are still afraid to return to
their homes so the Tremor was powerful
in Lebanon minor damage no reports of
casualties but Syria Syria is a
different story and as you've been
mentioning turkey as well Dave thank you
so much for that update that's in a
horror for us in Beirut
is the Middle East Regional director for
the Syrian American Medical Society he
says the situation in Northern Syria is
dire
it was an awful earthquake it
took long time for for us to understand
what what's going on
very heavy everything inside the office
get shaking
and uh
we we used to go downstairs in the the
the in very difficult weather maybe you
can't see me sitting inside my car
alongside with my family because of the
instruction of the government not to go
to the to our homes
in those hours so very heavy rain and
the three minutes were very very very
awful and terrific and very difficult
for for us and for everyone we are here
in Turkey in in stable uh State and the
the the government doing it's it's best
to to help people and to respond but the
the the crisis is inside Syria
unfortunately at least in in Northwest
Syria it's a very very perfect situation
right now we got initial information
from our hospitals for about tens of
death is and hundreds of injured people
the the hospitals or hospitals are
overwhelmed uh from the number of of
casualties in those hospitals
unfortunately we used to evacuate one of
our maternity hospitals because of the
image
sustained because of the earthquake and
also we have uh at at least a five to
seven deaths in a shifa hospital in
Afrin
okay well let's bring in Kenan akbaram
from Bengal Tokyo he is the director for
the Center for Energy environment and
natural disasters at the University of
Bengal and I know that you've been now
watching some of these pictures coming
through we've seen buildings pancaked uh
and search and rescue workers
frantically trying to find people can
you explain the force that is needed to
do something like this to create so much
damage over such a large area
um actually we are very late for that I
mean for this earthquake at least uh we
we need to do this seismic risk and
Hazard analysis uh before this
earthquake comes
that means we had to check the
engineering structure of the soil and
the engineering structure of the uh
existed buildings and then we needed to
uh modified our buildings or or our
cities around these areas but
unfortunately we we didn't do that
foreign
obviously this is an earthquake prone
area lying on a fault line what
precautions were in place to deal with
large earthquakes like this I mean how
prepared is this region for something of
the scale
unfortunately this region is not
prepared I I cannot say that even the
western marmara or the marmara region or
the Asian region is prepared
I mean as I told you before I mean a lot
just seconds ago
we are just mapping the defaults and
that's fine we are just trying to
understand the behavior of the falls
that's also fine but that wasn't enough
that we need to do we need to do let's
say uh check the soil structures our
engineering structures uh we had to
concentrate it on those as a geologist
uh I am I am let's say um I don't want
to use a stupid word but I am happy to
know that we knew that this earthquake
coming but I am very sad to know that uh
the uh before the earthquake comes we
didn't do the preparations we mostly
focus on search and rest rescue which we
do very well I mean we are just trying
to save people we are experienced on
that but in terms of preparation wise
unfortunately while why wasn't it done
I mean in an area that we know is prone
to to large earthquakes
um
earthquake quotes and there are some
engineering numbers let's say we know
you know not exactly but we know partly
uh how many G's or the uh how many let's
say PGA will be called in engineering it
means gravity lateral gravity will occur
around the earthquake the brown regions
uh we knew that but we had to check the
buildings if they are uh just uh you
know uh solid if they're just uh they
will be ready to this kind of PGA values
we didn't do that and that's that's our
weakest Point that's why in every uh
let's say earthquakes uh we are just
witnessing this kind of disasters
you're talking about the building code I
mean we're looking at some of these
pictures of uh you know multiple story
apartment buildings uh pretty much
pancaked flat I mean is the building
code up to scratch there
well I I don't know actually I'm not a
civil engineer but the picture shows
shows us that uh they're not suitable
they they weren't uh just uh you know uh
using the exact codes or they were not
built very well yeah
and we've seen dozens uh of aftershocks
already in the in the hours since the
the first earthquake are we going to be
able to expect more of those to come
over the next few days
uh not only next few days but next two
or three years there will be uh large
aftershocks
their intensity will will drop in time
but uh in in two or three years uh we
will be waiting after shorts yeah okay
thank you so much for your your time and
your Insight that is Kenan at Byram from
Bengal turkey who is the director for
the center of energy environment and
natural disasters thank you very much
but let's bring in Mehmet silic from
Istanbul he is the editorial coordinator
for daily Sabah newspaper thank you very
much for joining us on Al Jazeera as we
continue our coverage of this earthquake
can you explain what the government's
doing right now to help those uh in the
worst affected areas
well we can easily say that the the
government and the whole state is
literally mobilized with all the
ministers to all the institutions and to
all the rescue search and rescue teams
uh being dispatched to the region so
everything at hand has been actually
mobilized and all the efforts are
underway at the moment and knowing that
the scope is very large and and the
region is very wide an international
call has also been made with the code
for level four emergency
uh uh you know sharing uh so there is an
international call as well but with
regards to what is being done
immediately all the ministers have been
dispatched some Governors have been
shifted around to to provide support to
the the to the regions and inexperienced
Governors with regards to the earthquake
management
but we know that you know the the they
have from other provinces from Istanbul
Ankara other regions uh rescue teams
have also been uh dispatched uh you know
the communications directory directorate
have been managing the communication
parts of it the health and and red
president and and disaster and
management uh has been uh coordinating
their relevant parts so literally a
whole state mobilization is currently
underway
um as the scope is really really large
and you know 10 province is being
affected is not something that turkey
has experienced previously despite the
fact that is one of the one of the you
know earthquake bronze countries in the
region
well can you just explain a little bit
about those those regions those
provinces to to those of us who might
not know much about them I mean how
large are some of the cities and how
remote are some of the areas
well these regions are you know pretty
much urbanized regions in south eastern
part of turkey they are very developed
in terms of their urban areas but rural
areas are we cannot say that they are as
urbanized or as developed uh they're
very modern cities uh they are in the
you know they are some of the key
developed regions so with that we can
say that you know the the infrastructure
is very strong however uh you know when
we look at the number of collapsed
buildings we can say that the the uh the
earthquake code or or the safety codes
with regards to buildings and
constructions
is is unfortunately not followed in some
of them or some of these collapsed
buildings were built prior to this
regulation so they are very modern
cities they're in the Southeastern part
of turkey they're very they're some of
the key populated cities in the region
they're not small cities with regards to
their popular Nation but they're very
urbanized uh and and this urbanization
you know creates that density in some of
the urban centers but uh the fact that
it's a very large area makes things a
little bit more difficult uh when it
comes to focusing on uh rescue uh and
search uh efforts
obviously we know that this is an
earthquake prone area lying on on a
major fault line I mean looking at some
of these pictures that of what do you
make of of the building code that was in
place and do you think that um it was
good enough uh seeing some of the images
that are coming through now
well you know looking at the pictures
and looking at it from Far uh after the
things happen it's something but you
know and whether the inspections were
done whether the these buildings uh were
safe and they were on par with the code
it's something else unfortunately it is
a measure that had to be taken uh prior
to the uh prior to the uh earthquake and
we know that you know this regulation
has been in place following the 1999
elections but uh you know that
transformation hasn't taken place with
many areas that are prone to earthquakes
particularly uh you know Istanbul for
example is one of those cities that is
you know on the fault lines and a major
earthquake is being expected a
transformation has as began but it's not
complete yet and with the same goes with
many areas uh uh you know that are
earthquake prone across the whole
country
what do you think is going to be the
political impact or the Fallout from
this you know Turkey is having elections
later this year
well yes elections are approaching but
this is you know at times like this uh
this is one of the good things about
Turkish politics is that politics are
put aside despite the fact that there's
an election coming at times like this
politics are put aside and a whole state
and all the all the parties mobilize uh
to to you know create that sense of
unity however after the after this uh
you know after the shocks
how the government will be dealing with
the the damage will be one of the key
determinants I think when it comes to
the you know the the elections in May
um however it is too early to talk about
politics uh for my from my perspective
uh at this moment and I think uh you
know Turkey even you know has had
previous earthquakes uh you know at the
time of the earthquake politics comes uh
not at first uh thing that comes to mind
we've already seen a number of countries
uh pledge assistance and and help
including the United States what does
Tiki need uh in the initial uh days and
and weeks after this this earthquake
uh Vice President Ford I was speaking
earlier he said that you know when it
comes to transportation and some of the
other needs to give very uh sufficient
but medical uh medical uh assistance as
well as rescue and and search and rescue
teams are some of the you know helps
that turkey will need again as I said
earlier the the scope is very large so
having a large number of experience and
qualified teams would be I think
critical uh to to you know save some
lives okay thank you so much for your
time uh that's from uh the daily suburb
newspaper where he is the managing
editor thanks very much for being on Al
Jazeera
well let's bring you the latest on this
major earthquake here's what we know so
far a magnitude 7.8 earthquake struck
the southeastern region of bazajik there
are casualties reported in both turkey
and Syria at least
284 people have been killed in Tokyo
after the Quake which rocked the Turkish
Syrian border region Tokyo's Vice
President says more than 2 000 people
have been injured for what octay says
gazian tip airport has suspended civil
flights Syrian media says about 240
people have been killed there a state of
emergency has been declared in some
parts of Syria and some places are under
a disaster Zone
well the White House has reacted to the
earthquake National Security adviser
Jake Sullivan says the U.S is profoundly
concerned adding Washington stands ready
to provide assistance he said that
President Biden has directed usaid and
other federal government Partners to
assess response options to help those
affected and the U.S will continue to
monitor the situation in coordination
with the government of Tokyo
Umi culson the sheriff has more on the
earthquake
the debris are trying to reach survivors
the operation made Harder by a winter
storm
[Music]
four level
s announced by the offered Turkish
disaster Authority it means and its
International
uh disaster International level disaster
the quick stroke remote areas in Eastern
Turkey harder to access at the best of
times but early rescue efforts are also
being hindered by bad weather
Ankara is calling for international help
with more than 10 cities affected
neighboring Syria has also been hit hard
casualties are mounting the regions of
Aleppo Hama and Latakia are among the
worst affected
[Music]
civilian buildings have completely been
destroyed due to an earthquake that hit
the northwest of Syria around 4 30 in
the morning the situation is dire and
catastrophic tens of buildings have
fallen in the city of selkin is a
complete electrical blackout it's really
catastrophic everyone is on the streets
the buildings are either destroyed or
barely holding here
the Quake was felt throughout the
Eastern Mediterranean including Lebanon
Cyprus Palestine Israel and as far as
Egypt turkey sits on top of major
seismic fault lines and is frequently
shaken by earthquakes some 18 000 people
were killed in Quakes that hit the
Northwest in 1999.
Sharif al-jazeera